si près et bien voici la première
question que vous avez choisi qui nous
vient de montréal du gers et qui est
posée par mademoiselle rosina me tiens
quel est le numéro matricule de l'agent
secret créé par le romancier gamme pris
0,09
alors oss 117 le nom suis ian fleming
bienvenus james bond 0,09
cependant vous me suivez en 07 00 chef
james bond bien le 32e championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur route a eu lieu à
saint sébastien le premier championnat
une en 1927 qui en fut le vainqueur de 6
cm bonne réponse maintenant votre
capitaine nous a parlé de cofidis et à
ses invités rien faire je bande à
alfredo binda bobine d'or vous êtes
jeune vous pourriez vous reconnaitre
barda et après le bain d'avril et
rapportera 1 madame de faivre résidence
du 6 au 11 avenue mirabeau à l'aube au
celi oise amendable de la fin d'un franc
et de mon côté mon frère je vais tout
heureux de vous offrir sous les
acclamations de vous améliorer
[Applaudissements]
le premier volet de la loterie nationale
est un jeu loué le jeu des mille francs
lucien jeunesse votre voix très connue
des auditeurs de france inter mais
qu'est ce qui nous vaut le plaisir de
votre visite dans notre région vient
vous savez que nous enregistrons l'hiver
le jeu des mille francs en province et
en particulier dans les collèges et nous
sommes venus à epernay et à reims
enregistré une douzaine d'émissions
nous avons d'ailleurs rencontré des
candidats très sympathique et très
brillant notamment l'école des
beaux-arts de reims nous avions des gens
très très vivant qui s'en va ce
passionné s'intéresser à beaucoup de
choses
ce qui est très intéressant de voir ça
permet de faire également un petit test
sur la sur la jeunesse actuelle
moi je pense que ce qui vous intéressera
peut être c'est de savoir comment se
comportent les candidats vous savez que
dans le jeu des mille francs il y a la
possibilité de gagner le banco c'est à
dire mille francs et le super banco
c'est à dire 3000 les candidats doivent
choisir trois questions bleues de
blanche et une rouge correspondant pour
les questions bleues à 20 francs puis 40
francs pour la question blanche et 80
pour la question rouge lorsque le
candidat gagne c'est à dire découvre la
question ils gagnent les 40 francs ou
les 80 francs lorsqu'il ne trouve pas à
la question
eh bien nous en voyons cet argent aux
auditeurs qu'ils ont envoyée car tout le
monde est gagnant dans ce jeu où
l'auditeur ou le candidat c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs ce jeu marche aussi bien
depuis tant d'années
[Musique]